ja mein aufreger des tages ist das ist
manchmal jetzt in der wissenschaft
plötzlich mit hohem gibt wie man
bestimmte wissenschaftliche positionen
einfach komplett mundtot machen kann was
geht folgendermaßen man argumentiert
sozusagen von außen ja dass man sagt es
gibt einzelne positionen innerhalb der
wissenschaft genau richtig sind das ist
eine objektive wahrheit und damit zum
pastor rückte später die irgend etwas
ganz anderes machen dass das eine
prozent was in ganz andere dinge
behauptet und wenn ihr journalisten
darüber berichten dann heißt das angebot
durch diese these dann wollen die immer
ausgewogen berichten und nehmen sich
dann immer nicht nur aus den 99 prozent
dieses dann die wahrheit haben der
wissenschaftler welchen und die suchen
sich immer absichtlich einen der
aussenseiter machen damit aber ein
fehler weil sie das mit der politik
verwechselt wurden unterschiedliche
meinungen haben kann und will man damit
argumentiert heißt das natürlich dass
man sozusagen alle vom mainstream
abweichende meinungen komplett einfach
unter den teppich kehren könnte und dass
jetzt die sozusagen echte filterfunktion
von draußen stattfinden würde und
irgendwelche journalisten oder ganz
externen die vielleicht bei korrektiv
oder sowas sitzen sozusagen über die
wahrheit befinden und den professoren
streit eingreifen also dass dann endlich
studenten die dann eben schon korrektiv
machen auf einmal darüber befinden
können was jetzt die wahrheit ist die
echte und was eben nicht
ich würde den sofa zu stimmen ganz
besonders auch bei der frage der
bewertung von corona dass insbesondere
beim beginn der krise vor allem auf
einzelne experten gehört wurde nämlich
auf christian drosten weniger aufwendige
strikt auf karl lauterbach weniger auf
wolfgang kubicki und auch eine
mediale meinung entstanden ist dadurch
dass man das schild erhoben hat und
gesagt hat wir sind diejenigen die die
menschen beschützen und hier wird keiner
sterben wenn wir diese politik verfolgen
und das wird nicht passieren und die
andere seite ganz schnell denunziert
werden konnte und da würde ich sagen
spielen dann doch die sozialen medien
eine große rolle insbesondere twitter
als meinungs- gegebenes medium vor allem
bei journalisten und politikern dass das
ganze sehr sehr in eine lichtung
gestoßen weil das sagen dies eine
prozent ging es ja noch nicht mal mehr
es wäre noch verständlicher gewesen aber
wenn ich sehe dass ist erschreckend wie
selbst wirklich seriöse virologen
seriöse wissenschaftler wie strick was
sie für einen shitstorm erlebt haben ja
das überhaupt nicht mehr angehört worden
sind zeitweise auch nicht ins kanzleramt
eingeladen worden es gab es einfach
nicht und da muss man sich schon
ernsthaft fragen in welche richtung
bewegen wir uns die war hochgradig
seriös nichts komisches drang kein kein
verschwörungstheoretiker und wasser und
das ist schon eine richtung die wir ganz
stark aufpassen da wird aus der seiten
der politik ist ja klar dass ich das
gerne haben wollen ja die wollen
natürlich ihren job nicht machen wollen
sich hinter irgendwelchen
wissenschaftlern verstecken und dann ist
das letzte was sie gebrauchen können
dass es da unterschiedliche positionen
innerhalb der wissenschaft gibt also von
seiten der politik verstehe vollkommen
dass sie diese dieser tour verlieren
aber naja sind ja politiker aber bei den
journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade tatsächlich sind abweichende
meinungen zu finden also die sind ja
letztlich dagegen die sind das
gegengewicht dazu und innerhalb der
wissenschaft müssen sich sowieso klar
darüber sein dass natürlich immer ein
paradigma sozusagen gerade die
wissenschaft dominiert und deshalb
gerade im rampenlicht steht und alle
anderen die ganzen kleinen trabanten
sind natürlich immer kleiner aber jede
wissenschaftliche neuerung steht hier
entsteht ja gerade durch diese trabanten
raus ich höre oft als gegenargument was
würde denn passieren wenn jetzt
irgendwelche leute einfach ankommen und
sagen die erde wäre flach sollte man
denen auch zuhören dann erinnere ich
immer daran das ist mal ein zeitlang gab
für 100 prozent der wissenschaftler
gesagt haben die erde ist flach sollte
man da denjenigen zu hören die gesagt
haben sie gewohnt und verdammt noch mal
das war genau das richtige das zu tun
denen zuzuhören ich habe mich heute sehr
über die these gefreut muss ich sagen
dass ich heute mittag erfahren dass sie
die mitbringen weil das ist auch ein
thema was mich umtreibt und der würde
ich auch den journalismus angreifen weil
da haben sie vollkommen recht am anfang
als die krone ab anime ausbrach hatte
ich manchmal das gefühl journalisten
haben mehr damit zu tun irgendwie
also bilder zu hause selber dann auch zu
veröffentlicht man sich wir bleiben uns
alle zu hause anstatt mal etwas
kritisches hinterfragen
jan fleischhauer müssen ich muss mich
jetzt an seinen worten bedient weil ich
dir so grandios fand denn fleisch hat
damals in einer kolumne sehr früh
übrigens als er war einer der frühen
chance des hinterfrage hat gesagt er ist
immer so jemand wenn alle nach links
gehen neigt er sich nach rechts oder
muss jetzt ehrlich mal sagen wie kann es
sein dass 95 prozent der johnson
applaudieren solche zustimmungswerte
hätte ja nicht mal als hitler gehabt als
sie ein fleischwolf immer jemand der
gerne provoziert ich fand das damals
aber richtig und das schlimme ist ich
erinner mich heute noch einen
journalisten die am anfang dagegen
geschrieben das war thomas thumann vom
handelsblatt der sehr frühen großen
artikel geschrieben das war auch julian
reichelt und auch jan fleischhauer aber
es waren einfach zu wenige die am anfang
auch schon mal hinterfragt haben dafür
musste man ja gar nicht sagen alle sind
falsch aber die mal kritisch hinterfragt
haben was passiert ist jede maßnahme
richtig und da muss man ehrlich sagen es
war zu wenig und es ist ein großes
versagen für mich vom journalismus
gewesen dass am anfang vor allem der
pandemie zu wenig gefragt wurde aber
jetzt hast du rosey köppel vergessen der
hat auch immer
schreiben also
nicht sagen
dass ich sie eigentlich mein
journalistisches programm bei der
weltwoche die andere sicht ich habe den
journalismus immer so verstanden dass
wenn alle in eine richtung laufen
da musst du durch das intelligenteste
argument finden um aufzuzeigen dass die
anderen wieder irgend einem falschen
goldenen kalb hinterherlaufen und also
zu provozieren leicht läufst du ja den
deutschen internet aber das wichtigste
in unserer kultur in unserer
gesellschaft in unserer demokratie das
wichtigste grundprinzip ist rede und
gegenrede freie rede die freie
diskussion wenn du die nicht mehr hast
dann hast du ein problem und das problem
der menschen bestimmt besteht darin dass
alle sagen nein ich bin natürlich immer
für die meinungsfreiheit frau bosbach
asam aber wenn du da einmal eine andere
meinung bringst dann hat der andere
plötzlich die inquisitoren augen trifft
dann siehst du da plötzlich eine einzige
guillotine da sitzen dann das gar nicht
geht schädels zeigst du ja also ich bin
aber
auch das ist genau die trifft den nagel
auf den kopf wir sind heute in einer
zeit wo es immer mehr leute gibt um mein
verdacht ist die kommunisten von links
die linken wollen nicht mehr diskutieren
sie wollen nur noch befehlen warum weil
die linken gemerkt haben dass wenn frei
diskutiert wird dann verlieren sie weil
sie dem echten leben möchte ich an der
sprechanlage kaffee und sarah einmal
wieder auf die mannschaft wieder auf
höchstem niveau in aber machen
soviel zur akzeptanz anderer mann
schon mal weg dass ich mich irgendwie
ich finde vor allem das argument trifft
nicht zu dass nur linke beleidigt sind
oder ich sage mal keine gegenrede zu
lassen wollen sondern sehr sehr häufig
erlebt ich das auch in konservativeren
rechten kreisen insbesondere
interessanterweise beim thema corona
weil ich ist ja völlig in ordnung finde
und ich bin gegen eine impfpflicht ich
bin gegen radikale maßnahmen aber in den
kreisen kommt schon vor so erlebe ich
dass wenn man dann sagt ja aber ich
lasse mich impfen ja oder darüber
spricht dass man sich impfen lässt dass
man dann von dieser seite ein drüber
kriegt das man könne das nicht mehr
hören dass leute sagen dass man sich
impfen lässt und was man überhaupt wie
kann man nur wenn die wahl eigentlich
mit der oder erstaunte oder beim thema
locker und zum beispiel auch ja das
thema alle themen die emotionalisieren
gehen in beide richtungen in einer
brachialität mittlerweile und ich bleib
dabei also ich glaube dass die
verkürzung sozusagen in den sozialen
medien insbesondere bei twitter
instagram ist freundlicher dazu geführt
hat dass man in dem diskurs bettelt er
benutzt die bevölkerung noch gar nicht
mit der gabel aus medienschaffenden
journalisten aber ich meinte eher
bewusst jetzt auch schon ich habe nur
gesagt was ich will jemand auf
allerhöchstem niveau argumentiert und
ich würde natürlich in diesem punkt so
gar nicht geben da stimmt ich möchte
nicht sozusagen von denen diskriminiert
werden ja sagen also der decke impfte so
nicht diskriminiert wenn der ungeimpfte
sondern auch nicht diskriminiert wenn
ich muss mich vor niemandem
entschuldigen aber jetzt mit meiner
natürlich viel weitergehenden
lebenserfahrung ich bin ja etwa 50 jahre
älter als du paul kann ich natürlich
sagen beachtlich dass die linke die noch
in den 60er und 70er jahren ein
anarchisches freiheits bringendes gen
haftet ist heute für mich in diesem
inquisitoren gesichter verein ich habe
das immer mit der verlegung in den
redaktionen wenn ich wieder mit
irgendeiner these gekommen bin die jetzt
nicht unbedingt im linken salat kann so
überraschend wurde ja ich bin ja
eigentlich durch den linken journalismus
von meinem vielleicht ursprünglich auch
mal linken sympathien er etwas geheilt
wurden aber fleischhauer hat recht wenn
er thomas mann zitiert wenn das bo nach
rechts geht muss du nach links gehen
aber heute geht es eben zu sehen nach
links da musst du nach rechts ausbauen
soll